[Music]
you guys ever had a dream yeah i had one
last night but what's up what was your
dream
a nightmare i murdered two people on how
to get rid of their bodies yeah what was
the method of disposal i don't know but
they're in the shower and then um
someone gave me a nail clipper
and said
just like chop it up that's all you can
use oh [ __ ] that's a cracker i was
crying because i was like this is not
going to [ __ ] work dude can you
imagine the little piece that used to uh
cut out your toes
you she cutting real skin like clipping
on top like trying to [ __ ] sit there
it was so graphic and i was just like
all right i gotta go to like home depot
and get some real [ __ ] but i'm like
that's how they always catch people
though so so what if you had that dream
and when you woke up you actually were
clipping something with the nail
clippers whoa
because that's what happened to this one
dude he started clipping his toenails
and [ __ ] man one time i had a dream
where i was peeing in the bed and i woke
up and my bed was wet
yeah
like that yeah yeah so this man i lucid
dreams sometimes and i've like yes this
man
yeah everybody else
you ever had a dream
and if you if you if you want to do it
so much and i lucy dreams that sex and
then i woke up and i had nutted
wait you really had a wet dream like
legit yeah like like i made it happen
dude i've never had a wet dress ever
ever ever dude i've never had i've never
had one either you guys jack off too
much is that what it is i like wet
dreams oh you guys are so lucky i rarely
get like six streams dude i don't
remember the last time
are the best they're pretty lit they're
very liberating i have sex dreams but i
don't come wrong when i was 15 back to
my no man we're talking about our own
dreams man we're talking about dreams
when i was 15 and i hit puberty i was
like when i was like in that stage of
puberty i was having wet dreams all the
time but now that i lucid dream when i
realized that i'm lucy dreaming i'm like
oh i know what's going on now i'm gonna
[ __ ] something oh you're so lucky so
then i'll like switch out like i've
literally like in between pumps have
switched between different girls oh i'm
so oh you're so lucky
and i got jizz everywhere that's crazy
lucid and wet dreamed that's freaking
wow that's the highest level of
inception yeah you could be an inceptor
and you're like a [ __ ] monk dude dude
it's pretty it's pretty um you should
just self-induce a coma you're dr
strange yeah well here's what's great is
that in this article this guy
that's amazing so you want to know huh
no i could talk about dreams for hours
i'll show you four more and then
sorry i started it
up the [ __ ] clipping okay it was a
good transition
this man
cut off his own penis
in his sleeve
while dreaming he was chopping meat he
wasn't he wasn't dreaming right yeah oh
where'd he get the knife
yeah seriously
how did he get the knife would you cut
coke did he go into the kitchen like i
just imagined him going into the kitchen
and he's like ooh bratwurst
oh
so a man in ghana has cut his own penis
and scrotum off oh it's ghana now
damn that was fire
cut off his own penis and scrotum
in his sleep while dreaming that he was
chopping me waking up in horror before
calling neighbors scrotum too
oh my pain tolerance is too high
he's [ __ ] cutting it off while he's
sleeping doesn't even know wow well
that's why like surgery works right
because you're sleeping
no but you're numb and [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's why it works yeah
you're sleeping and now you're not awake
no notifications you die
so this guy's name is kofi coffee
whatever a farmer from this area in
south ghana
suffered critical injuries in the
incident uh after dreaming about
slaughtering a goat so you better watch
out next time you murdered two people in
the bathroom okay i'm glad i don't sleep
walk
the flashlight's
after feeling sharp pains coming from
his penis and scrotum that must africa
and hurt
sorry i'm not mad i like it
anthony you got
no
any
want to add on
i i want to add on but then i'm looking
at this quote because uh he he was
quoted four days later speaking to uh
bbc and stuff but the thing is they oh
dude
it's like written phonetically can you
can you read that line
i'm reading
the article
let the record show
cut that part out editor i they sit
inside chair way i doze off so as i day
sleep i dream say i they cut meat way
day in front of me
what did they do in phonetics that's
what i'm saying i'm like why would you
quote this phonetically like that but at
the same time great job quoting
here is a uh a a japanese porn picture
that's associated with the uh aftermath
it's pixelated
oh got it oh no man hi
his penis is white why is that uh i
think that's a dick cast
it was really afraid when he did it so
it's freaked now
the blood went away sheesh got pale yeah
this is that's gotta be you guys ever so
they were able to save it
no save him
that's a true nightmare well he was
taken to the hospital for treatment but
uh said he may need surgery which he'll
need to raise the funds for goal fund
oh that's why he did it
he needed some extra money it's all
[ __ ] scary he's starting to go fund
me so he can pay for a new car
we need a like a new retort insult when
people ask for funds just say go fund
yourself
why can't it all it's always like
horrible [ __ ] that happens when you
sleepwalk why can't it be the opposite
like you like when the lotto like you
bought a lotto ticket and you're like oh
my god do chores oh the surveillance
camera for 7-eleven she says yeah
you wake up and you [ __ ] wrote like
the best [ __ ] song ever or like you
you woke up and then you have a script
done like you just go to sleep and then
you're productive somehow you're walking
around the kitchen and then you're like
you bake the cheesecake or something
yeah you wake up and your whole room's
clean yeah yeah get yourself a sandwich
for when you woke up that'd be lit that
would be cool breakfast sandwich well
[ __ ] dietrich used to say that he
could he could so lucid dream so well
that if he like
wrote something a script in his sleep he
would like remember the whole [ __ ] when
he woke up and it was like done does he
feel rested when he woke up though yeah
yeah yeah what really do you you lucid
dream a lot you said right on occasion
it's been a minute yeah right but when
you guys lose a dream do you guys feel
like well rested when you wake up or do
you feel like i need to lose my dream it
doesn't feel any different i'm hacking i
always feel like i'm extra tired really
that's what happens when i feel like i
don't sleep if i read before i go to
sleep yeah when i'm sleeping i'm just
thinking about what i read and i wake up
like i [ __ ] didn't even sleep really
and then meanwhile your dick's gone yeah
yeah yeah dreaming is when you can
realize it and control it right the only
time i can do that is when i'm flying
in my oh in my dream not flying on an
airplane that's what we meant
the minute i know i'm dreaming i wake up
so that's how i started lucid dreaming
because i would always wake up once i
realized oh this is a dream that i wake
up i'm just a white belt then
yes you gotta work on it he just
mastered so here's what you do dog
masturbator you once you [ __ ] realize
you're dreaming just calm yourself down
okay that's how i did it like because i
one day i was just like okay you're
dreaming relax don't wake up don't wake
up don't wake up i consciously told
myself that and then i didn't wake up
and once i realized i was in it i was
like let me go try and fly and i could
fly and i'd be like oh i want a hammer
in my hand a hammer would pop up and
then you start to just start to control
your environment and it always leads to
sex well it started to because the first
time i was 15. i was like no no no no
wet dreams when i was 15. free cheating
yeah with legal cheating so the first
time i did it
it was with chia because i was like in a
dream with her it's a nightmare and then
i realized i was lucid dreaming and then
i was like my wife is here i can have
sex you know what i'm saying so then we
started having sex and then it wasn't
until like my second lucid dream i was
like oh i don't have to have sex with my
wife this is a dream
so you have less guilt that's oh there's
no guilt
yeah it's pretty cool
i heard uh my homie said that in order
for him to break through uh
with his lucid dream he gave himself
like a totem as well yeah i mean i've
seen that on instagram say that did he
say that after that movie came out or
before the idea of it i did it so this
whole goes to sleep with the [ __ ]
monopoly toy
i think for him it was like a drawing of
like happy face on his thumb
really yeah it was something like that
so he sleeps i know he has to do that
and then go to sleep i think it's like
if he saw the happy face then he knew he
was dreaming
versus if it wasn't it was some weird
[ __ ] like too complicated you guys have
dreams every night i would say like now
i don't have any [ __ ] dreams
and once in a while they pop up
i have dreams every night but sometimes
i don't know yeah yeah it's hard to
remember
like in the in the morning when you wake
up you remember that you had a dream i
like don't count that as a dream when
like things happen but you don't
remember kind of like you didn't like
feel something
[ __ ] just happens i feel like that's
just like flashes from my brain but when
i like uh there's like a plot line even
if it doesn't make sense but there's
like a progressive experience yeah yeah
then it's a dream dog i had a section
you know so intense one time and i was
right next to chia when it happened but
i was like humping in real life like my
body was thrusting as you were yelling
at some other dude's names
[Laughter]
not my regular dream this was
so i'm next to her thrusting until i
[ __ ] came and i woke up and i was
like did you feel that and she was like
yeah
and i put and i woke up and as i [ __ ]
had nutted and i was like oh was it good
for you too
did you enjoy yourself soon she was like
she's like yeah
what was his name this time
when i woke up from my dream i was like
damn she was scary but i couldn't let go
of
that there was no conclusion so i had to
solve how i was gonna get rid of the
body oh [ __ ]
when you're awake i was like i'll set
arson to the whole house
dude that's the worst is when you wake
up you wake up with the same process
from my dream yeah and it's so scary but
i had to finish it because it just
didn't feel complete
and then after yeah that happens a lot
though when i do dream and it's
unfinished i'm sitting in bed and i have
to finish it i i had a dream when i was
a kid that um that i was just like
laying in my bed this is in the dream i
was laying in my bed room looks the same
the closet door is open a little bit and
there's a guy in there just going
oh my god and then when i woke up i woke
up to the same [ __ ]
guy oh closet's closed oh
god oh sh [ __ ] me as a kid i was like oh
[ __ ] so it was one of those uh sleep
paralysis thing no it was just an actual
regular dream but then it was like
so what the [ __ ] is in there over the
door there's a huge hole
um you ever got you ever get like um not
necessarily just sleep paralysis but you
know in your dream when you're trying to
run away from something or trying to
chase somebody yeah you're slow yeah you
can't run so i had like i have that all
the time or not all the time but like i
have that right
and i remember i got bugged out like
maybe two weeks ago so bad because i was
[ __ ] like for me it's not just like
i'm slow i'm like i can't run with my
legs so i started like dragging my arms
across the street scary to get somewhere
and i was like man i [ __ ] suck and i
feel so uncomfortable so i finally had
to google it
you know
one source you know what it says what
you're gay yes
well that's the end of the video
it basically talks about how at that
part of that deep rem sleep you
literally uh have put physical paralysis
on your body
so your body is literally in a physical
position where it's like you can't move
but you're mentally aware interesting so
so there's this like disconnect where
you're trying to move
in your dream but in reality you
physically are incapable moving so that
combines into your story over to your i
see it's sleep process because your eyes
just open right sleep past is the other
way around where you're still in that
same type of zone where your body has
been kind of turned off to rest but then
you wake up and you're just like oh [ __ ]
you're not just wearing your dream
you're just genuine i've never had sleep
problems
but i've had it where i'm like i'm about
to get in a fight with the guy and i'ma
[ __ ] you up and i go
it's gonna hit you real soon
they're at normal speed but we're not
that's how they have sleep
i'm like getting parallels in the face
like 20 times but i'm all [ __ ] because
in this in this parallel universe that
you're meeting this other person they're
lucy dreaming and they're like oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] bartquart
[Laughter]
doesn't that happen when you have dance
dreams like when i if i have dance
dreams where i'm like in the middle of
like a battle and i can feel like i
could win it in the dream i'm just going
why could i do any of my moves
[Music]
[Music]